[Music]
[Applause]
uh Jeff Miller was there he gets paid to
cover it from the LA Times that's combat
pay man Jeff joining us now if I didn't
watch it how would you describe what
happened last night if you didn't watch
it first off congratulations you made
the right decision um it it that was an
absolute abomination it was an
embarrassment uh I've been doing this
almost 40 years Dan I don't know that
I've ever seen a team perform more
poorly than that that was it was just
the words embarrassment and like the
players openly talked about it after the
game they were embarrassed they know it
they know they just they what they did
was just
unacceptable uh will
the we already knew Brandon Staley's job
was you know already in Jeopardy there
but could the Chargers why why would the
chargers keep him for the rest of the
regular
season a tradition frankly they this is
not a franchise that typically lets go
of coaches in the middle of a season or
during a season um so really that's
about the only reason I can think of uh
you know this the most solid reason why
they wouldn't do it another one is they
there isn't a clear you know former head
coach or somebody on the staff who they
could just turn things over to and say
hey get us through the last three weeks
here and uh you know and and thanks for
your efforts because they don't have
they don't have anybody like that I mean
Kell Moore is a guy who maybe could be a
head coach but really on the staff that
there isn't that you know senior advisor
type you know Jason Garrett type
somebody who would be on the staff who
they could turn to and say okay just
just get us through the end of this
please I was wondering good and you
don't like use the word quit but man it
felt like there were some guys last
night who did not want to be there you
get that sense when you went into the
locker room room yeah I I don't know so
much it was just you know these guys
gave up and they just surrendered
they've been through this has been a
rough year that the expectations of
weight on these guys going back to
training camp I I think more than just
hey this is an indictment on the
character of some of these players I
think it was just these guys are human
and they they know where this is going I
mean they they know as you know as well
as those of us are on the team that this
this was probably going to get blown up
and that's uh and so I think when when
you have back-to-back turnovers
consecutive offensive plays where you
turn the ball over and the other team
goes down and scores I think it was just
natural at one point during that game
everybody was gonna say hey this you
know this is over let's what what are we
doing here this is just a nightmare so I
I think probably there was some of that
but I think honestly in my opinion it
was more of that than you know these
guys are you know are bad you know bad
character guys or they just gave up how
desirable is this
job well it's you know know it starts
with Justin Herbert that that's the
biggest thing that's the one thing
you've got you know if you get this job
you don't have to worry about the
quarterback so that makes it very
desirable now with where it they that
falls a little bit short is you know
this is not a team we all know has never
won anything they uh the ownership is
you know they've you know there's been
questions about about that they're
they're you know they don't have a ton
of cash they're they have to do some
Financial gymnastics at times to make
things work but all NFL teams figure it
out and and uh and the GM here will
figure it out whoever it is um but I I
think it's desirable just because of
Justin Herbert and you know the one
thing is that the Spanos is they'll
spend money they'll invest in guys we've
seen it so it's not like they're cheap
that way it's just they don't have the
cash to do some of the things that you
know especially in season things that
some some teams can do what's the fan
interest I've been in La now a couple
couple of years but have they been
embraced you know there's so much
competition in in h town but how how
would you rank that fan Bas like are
they angry are they passionate where
they you know they're calling for change
here the the the charger fans the real
fans they they're very passionate the
problem is there just not a ton of them
but you they were chanting for Staley to
get fired last home game so they're
they'll make some noise and there's
there's people trust me all you got to
do is go on social social media and
there's there's a lot of Venom and a lot
of anger out there uh it's just that
there's not a ton of them and the fact
that this team has never want anything
you know from the national perspective I
don't think you get much attention and
there's not you know fans around the
country don't really care that much
about the treasures because they never
win they're never relevant so uh I would
say though in this market um I'm not
going to say embraced I mean other than
the Dodgers and Lakers and when USC
football's good I don't you know
everybody struggles to to show up on the
radar but uh but there's the charger
fans that are passionate I mean there's
there there's believe me there's some
that are I get emails I get this thing
blows up when they uh or text messages
and DMS and uh there's a lot of anger
this morning believe me would you rather
be a charger fan today or an angels fan
today oh wow see that's interesting
because I covered both these teams so I
know both of them pretty well uh I would
I you know I'd rather be a charger fan
just because of Justin Herbert and the
fact that they're they're rarely boring
the angels can be boring uh the Chargers
generally AR I think Chargers are more
entertaining and sometimes it's in a
terrible way but they are more
entertaining so I would go uh I'm gonna
go with the Chargers great to talk to
you Jeff thanks for joining us all right
Dan anytime thank you that's Jeff Miller
he covers the Chargers for the LA Times
how about that he gets the angels and
the
Chargers yay how's morale